we all remember Vince Carter and Tracy
McGrady in their iconic 2000 dunk
contest but did you know that even
before that the cousins faced off in
their own dunk contest in the 1999
preseason Vince was being himself
amazing the crowd with highlights out of
this world T-Mac was encouraged to join
in on the fund for the fans and he
quickly became a One V one Dunk Contest
between cousins determined to show one
another up Vince went deep in his bag
Vince would teas a dunk that would lead
to him doing something for the first
time as a pro fast forward to Allstar
Weekend in 2000 the dunk contest is back
for the first time since 1997 and both
Vince and Tac enter the competition the
cousins would team up at Vince's third
dunk taking what he teased to another
level leading to Kenny The Jet Smith
emphatically saying it's over ladies and
gentlemen and Vince made sure everyone
knew it too giving us one of the most
legendary moments in dunk contest
history but it all started with a
preseason dunk contest for fun between
cousins that would changed the real
thing forever